Con un tipo de cambio inicial de 1,1789 dólares
estadounidenses, el día 1 de enero del año
1999 ha pasado a la historia como el día
en el que nació el euro.
Comenzó a operar como una moneda electrónica
utilizada en los mercados financieros y para
los pagos sin efectivo.
Aunque no sería hasta 3 años más tarde,
hasta comienzos del año 2002 cuando las monedas
y los billetes de euros que hoy todos conocemos
comenzaron a circular. El 1 de enero de 1999,
11 países de la Unión Europea integraron
sus monedas locales - monedas como el marco,
el franco la lira o la peseta - bajo el paraguas
supervisor del Banco Central Europeo.
La era del euro había comenzado.
Y lo hizo por todo lo alto. Las expectativas
eran enormes.
Tal vez nadie manifestó mejor la enorme confianza
depositada en esta nueva moneda que el entonces
comisario europeo para Asuntos monetarios,
Yves-Thibault.
Desde entonces han pasado 20 años, un tiempo
en el que la nueva divisa europea ha pasado
por buenos y por malos momentos… Algo que,
por cierto, en no pocas ocasiones ha condicionado
el debate público.
Porque, amigos, no lo neguemos, la actualidad
es irremediablemente pesimista. El catastrofismo
y las malas noticias llaman más la atención
que los acontecimientos positivos. En nuestra
percepción la última noticia vence a la
tendencia.
De esta forma, durante los últimos años
hemos escuchado todo tipo de pronósticos
sobre lo que ha supuesto el euro y el futuro
de esta divisa.
Seguro que en alguna que otra ocasión habéis
escuchado eso de que el euro está condenado
o que su llegada a provocado que haya países
ganadores y países perdedores.
Ahora bien, ¿Cuál es la realidad? ¿Qué
evaluación podemos hacer de los 20 años
que el euro lleva formando parte de la vida
diaria de la inmensa mayoría de los europeos?
¿A qué retos y desafíos se enfrenta?
Pues bien, para responder a estas y otras
preguntas y celebrar también el 20 aniversario
de la divisa europea, gracias al apoyo y a
la esponsorización del Banco Central Europeo
nos hemos venido hasta aquí, hasta Frankfurt.
Precisamente, ese edificio es la
sede del poderoso Banco Central Europeo, la
segunda institución monetaria más importante
del planeta. Ahora tu y yo vamos a adentrarnos
en ese mundo para averiguar qué ha supuesto
el euro y a qué retos se enfrenta.
Así que, vamos allá.
(LA UNIÓN HACE LA FUERZA)
Creo que la primera pregunta que nos tenemos
que hacer es bastante clara, ¿Cómo y por
qué surge el euro?
Para responder a esta pregunta hay que remontarse
hasta los años 80, una década que no estaba
siendo particularmente buena para los europeos.
(En aquel momento, la economía Europa no
atravesaba por sus mejores tiempos. Eran años
de cierto estancamiento y malos datos.
Por ejemplo… El desempleo en los países
de la Comunidad Europea prácticamente se
había duplicado, pasando del 5,8% en 1980
a más del 11%, apenas 5 años más tarde;
el crecimiento potencial se había reducido
3 puntos;
Los déficit públicos empezaban a dejarse
notar con niveles por encima del 3%
Y para colmo Estados Unidos, principal cliente
de las exportaciones europeas estaba incrementando
de una forma muy sustancial las restricciones
comerciales a las importaciones..
Pues bien, es en este contexto como toma fuerza
la idea de construir un verdadero mercado
común que permitiera impulsar el comercio
y por tanto el crecimiento económico.
Crear un mercados sin barreras, sin aduanas,
sin aranceles, sin restricciones para todos
los bienes.
Para llevarlo a cabo había que suprimir todos
las trabas administrativas y terminar con
la disparidad de normas y regulaciones. Si
un producto se podía vender en un país de
la unión se tenía que poder vender en cualquier
otro.)
Pero... No solo eso. Un auténtico mercado
común tenía que funcionar también con la
misma moneda y con la misma política monetaria.
Entre otras cosas esto permitiría que los
países no compitieran entre sí devaluando
una y otra vez sus respectivas divisas.
Algo que en aquellos años era bastante habitual.
Por ejemplo, tan sólo entre 1979 y 1992 Italia
devaluó la lira 7 veces. En apenas 13 años,
7 devaluaciones.
Fijar una moneda común haría
que el comercio entre los países europeos
fuera mucho, muchísimo más fácil.
Las empresas ya no tendrían que estar pendientes
de los tipos de cambio, de las decisiones
de política monetaria de los diferentes gobiernos
o de las coberturas por riesgo de divisa,
entre otras muchas cuestiones.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? La creación del mercado
único ha sido un claro ejemplo de éxito.
Cumplió con su objetivo. Las exportaciones
intracomunitarias han pasado de suponer el
13% del PIB de la Unión Europea en 1992 a
más del 20% hoy en día. Y el volumen de
inversiones intracomunitarias también se
ha disparado.
Y, amigos, no lo dudéis ni un momento. En
todo este proceso el euro ha jugado un papel
clave.
Ahora bien, el euro lleva ya con nosotros
20 años.
¿Qué evaluación podemos hacer? ¿Ha sido
bueno o malo para la vida de los europeos?
(EL TIEMPO DEL EURO)
Amigos, durante los últimos 20 años Europa
ha cambiado mucho, en algunos casos para bien
y en otros pues…. Digamos que para no tan
bien.
Pero llegados a este punto te hago una pregunta,
sí, sí, a ti ¿Tu que crees? ¿Ha sido el
euro bueno o malo para Europa?
Pues amigos, con los datos en la mano creo
que podemos decir que, en general, su influencia
ha sido muy positiva. Es algo de lo que ya
os hemos hablado aquí en VisualPolitik.
Ahora bien, la pregunta
es ¿Cuánto de positiva?
Pongamos sobre la mesa algunos datos
(El euro es hoy la moneda de más de 340 millones
de personas y ha sustituido a las monedas
nacionales en 19 de los 28 estados que forman
la Unión Europea.
Desde su nacimiento, el PIB per cápita de
la zona euro se ha incrementado un 52% pasando
de unos 21.000 a más de 32.000€ y hoy la
tasa de participación laboral es más alta
en la zona euro que en los Estados Unidos.
A pesar de ello, la inflación se ha situado
de media en el 1,7%, una tasa inferior a la
de los setenta, ochenta y noventa. De hecho
el nivel de inflación de la eurozona en estos
veinte años ha sido inferior al de República
Federal Alemana en las dos décadas anteriores.)
Tal vez esto sea lo que explique la enorme
popularidad que tiene el euro. Fijaos, tan
solo el 20% de los europeos están en contra.
Según los últimos estudios tres de cada
cuatro ciudadanos europeos tienen buena opinión
de divisa y consideran que ha sido positiva.
[Y la verdad, no nos engañemos, no es extraño.
Estoy convencido de que si te ofrecieran tener
tus ahorros en euros o en pesetas - o en alguna
moneda que funcione hoy y se parezca a la
peseta - estoy convencido de que no tendrías
la menor duda.]
Ahora bien, un momento, porque no todo han
sido alegrías. Durante estos 20 años el
euro también se ha enfrentado a momentos
muy, pero que muy difíciles.
(LOS AÑOS TENSOS)
Entre los años 2008 y 2012 las cosas se pusieron
muy difíciles. La crisis estaba causando
muchos problemas en la mayoría de las economías
occidentales, y auténticas pesadillas en
algunos de los países pertenecientes a la
zona euro como Grecia, Irlanda, Italia, España
o Portugal.
Es ahí cuando aparece claramente la idea
de las dos europas.
(Por un lado los países del centro y del
norte de Europa. Países en general con altos
índices de productividad, industrias competitivas
y estados relativamente responsables.
Por el otro, países que históricamente habían
tratado de competir devaluando sus monedas
y que como gracias al euro eso ya no era posible
habían impulsado la demanda interna con cargo
a fuertes desequilibrios en sus balanzas de
pagos.
Es decir, para que nos entendamos, financiaban
gran parte de su gasto en consumo e inversión
con dinero procedente del exterior, básicamente
de los países del norte y centro de Europa.
Financiación, que en gran medida, fue a parar
al sector inmobiliario.
Por tanto, hablamos de países donde, en general,
los gobiernos no habían hecho las reformas
estructurales que les permitiera ser competitivos
y cuyos bancos estaban cargados de préstamos
ligados a la burbuja inmobiliaria…
Préstamos que por supuesto perdieron gran
parte de su valor cuando la burbuja pinchó.)
Grecia, Portugal, España e Irlanda - aunque
el caso de Irlanda es un poco diferente - necesitaron
de una forma u otra asistencia financiera.
En ese momento la desconfianza y los problemas
eran de tal magnitud que se especuló, como
habréis escuchado un montón de veces con
la posible ruptura del euro. Entre otras cosas
porque muchos estados europeos tenían que
pagar primas de riesgo tan altos que hacían
que su situación fuera del todo insostenible.
No podían financiarse.
Al final los países miembros de la Eurozona
decidieron hacer todo lo posible para evitar
ese escenario y fue ahí cuando el Presidente
del Banco Central Europeo, Mario Draghi pronunció
el 26 de julio del año 2012 estas famosas
palabras:
(“Conforme a nuestro mandato, el BCE está
listo para hacer lo que sea necesario para
preservar el euro. Y créanme, será suficiente.)
Es decir, que el Banco Central adoptaría
las medidas extraordinarias que fueran necesarias
para estabilizar el euro.
De esta forma el Banco Central comenzó a
otorgar préstamos a más largo plazo a los
bancos y a comprar algunos de los activos
que tenían en sus balances como por ejemplo
bonos gubernamental y bonos corporativos.
¿Para qué?
Pues que las empresas y los ciudadanos pudieran
pedir más préstamos y gastar menos en repagar
sus deudas. La idea es que esto llevaría
a un mayor crecimiento económico.
Pero, llegados a este punto la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es, ¿está realmente preparada
la eurozona para hacer frente a una nueva
crisis? ¿Qué puede suceder en el futuro
si uno de los países miembros del euro tiene
problemas?
Amigos durante los últimos años han aparecido
un montón de mecanismos diferentes que se
han puesto en marcha precisamente para fortalecer
la resistencia del euro.
[Ya os adelanto que los nombres se las traen]
Todos estos nuevos organismos tienen múltiples
funciones y objetivos como, por ejemplo, incrementar
la estabilidad financiera, aumentar la fortaleza
macroeconómica, prestar ayuda financiera
a los países miembros que la puedan necesitar
o mejorar la supervisión bancaria.
Por cierto, lograr una mayor integración
bancaria es otro de los objetivos clave que
ahora persigue el Banco Central Europeo.
Y eso no es todo, por otra parte se han reforzado
instituciones ya existentes como el Pacto
de Estabilidad y Crecimiento que exige un
límite del 3% en el déficit público y del
60% en la deuda pública de los países miembros.
Y también en virtud del llamado Pacto Presupuestario
Europeo, casi todos los países de la Unión
Europea han incluido en su legislación nacional
la exigencia de tener presupuestos equilibrados
a lo largo del ciclo.
[Esperemos que respeten su propia legislación]
Y el propio Banco Central Europeo también
ha visto incrementada sus capacidades para
hacer frente a situaciones de emergencia.
En fin, cómo veis se han hecho un montón
de cambios que tienen como objetivo reducir
el riesgo de crisis y llegado el caso limitar
su impacto.
La pregunta es ¿Es suficiente o hay que seguir
avanzando, por ejemplo con cierta unión fiscal?
Ese es, amigos, uno de los grandes debates
que existen ahora mismo en Europa.
Pero, un momento, las crisis no son el único
reto al que se enfrenta el Banco Central Europeo
y el Euro. La llegada de las criptodivisas
y blockchain también ha hecho que crezca
un interrogante:
¿Serán capaces las nuevas tecnologías financieras
de cambiar la forma con la que funciona el
dinero? ¿Representan una amenaza para las
monedas tradicionales?
Y esto nos lleva a otra cuestión importantísima,
fundamental: ¿Qué ocurre con la ciberseguridad?
Especialmente en un mundo dónde todo se registra
y funciona digitalmente.
Amigos, Europa tiene por delante muchísimos
retos, sobre algunos de los cuales ya os hemos
hablado en este canal. Desafíos como el envejecimiento
demográfico, la creciente competencia internacional,
los desequilibrios en las cuentas públicas
de muchos de los países miembros o incluso
definir exactamente que modelo de Europa queremos.
El próximo 26 de mayo se celebrarán en España
las elecciones al Parlamento Europeo. De una
forma u otra este es el momento en el que
todos los ciudadanos europeos tenemos la oportunidad
de alzar nuestra voz y decidir entre todos
cuál es el futuro que queremos para Europa
o porqué tipo de unión apostamos.
Así que… Ya sabéis.
De momento si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante echadnos una mano dandole a like.
Una vez más, muchas gracias al Banco Central
Europeo por toda su ayuda para poder realizar
este vídeo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.